y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia de kobe 19 en nuestro
continente a continuación les presento
algunos de los temas que vamos a tratar
en este episodio
eeuu anunció que levantará las
restricciones para el ingreso a ese país
las personas con el esquema completo de
vacunación con algunas de las vacunas
que esté avalada por la oms podrán
entrar a ese país eso sí deja por fuera
a algunas personas que han sido
inmunizadas con biológicos como la
vacuna sputnik de abdalá soberana
soberana 2 entre otras esto afecta
directamente a miles de ciudadanos
latinoamericanos veremos el alcance de
esta medida con nuestro corresponsal en
eeuu hablaremos también de brasil este
país ya superó los 100 millones de
personas vacunadas al menos con una
dosis de algunas de las vacunas que está
avalada contra el kobe 19 la cifra
evidencia el avance de la vacunación en
ese país en donde el presidente yair
bolsonaro ha evitado inocularse un
motivo que llevó a que le prohibieran a
un estadio por no estar vacunado a sí
mismo millones de estudiantes también se
preparan para regresar a clases
presenciales que está prudente es esta
medida lo veremos en unos minutos con
nuestra corresponsal en la ciudad de río
de janeiro y en nuestra consulta con el
doctor pérez hablaremos de los riesgos
que implica precisamente la apertura de
las fronteras de los países teniendo en
cuenta los avances de la vacunación que
ya estamos registrando en américa pero
también hablaremos de el retroceso en la
lucha contra enfermedades como por
ejemplo la tuberculosis todo esto en el
marco de la pandemia de covite 19 pues
vamos a comenzar el programa y
comenzamos con las cifras y lo hacemos
viendo cómo está el panorama de cómo
terminó esta semana el avance de la
pandemia kobe 19 en centroamérica en los
países de habla hispana dejamos de lado
a belice que es de habla inglesa vamos a
comenzar en guatemala que finaliza esta
semana con más de 580 mil casos y más de
14.200 personas han fallecido allí en el
vecino el salvador los casos ya superan
los 109 mil y los fallecidos son más de
3400 honduras
corta para el cierre de esta semana más
de 371 mil casos y ya más de diez mil
personas han fallecido en nicaragua las
cifras oficiales contabilizan más de
15.700 casos y más de 200 personas han
fallecido aunque según las cifras del
observatorio ciudadano indican que los
números son mucho más altos en costa
rica los casos superaron los 550 mil los
fallecidos ya superan también las 6 mil
700 personas vamos a finalizar en panamá
en donde los casos son más de 469 mil y
ya los fallecidos se contabilizan por
encima de los
vamos a conversar con el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez médico infectólogo de
asesor científico de france 24 está con
nosotros para nuestra consulta habitual
aquí en el programa doctor pérez buenas
noches gracias por estar con nosotros un
gusto saludarlo como siempre y
hablábamos de la apertura de las
fronteras en eeuu también uruguay se
prepara para ello que balance se puede
hacer dada el avance que ha tenido la
vacunación en esos países pero sin
embargo sigue siendo un riesgo que entre
el país personas de diferente
procedencia con vacunas algunos sin
vacunas o con tests con pcr algunos van
a ingresar allí sin vacunas o sin
pruebas
este va a ser un desafío de esa nueva
dinámica en la que tenemos personas que
hay una asimetría real en los países y
lo vemos en las citas que mencionábamos
antes en donde la vacunación en nuevos
países avanza más hay algunos biológicos
que no se recomiendan por ejemplo en el
ingreso de eeuu y en fines de este
problema va a ser un problema que la
apertura no se debe hacer sin hasta que
todos estudiamos en un 60 o 70 por
ciento a conaf que hay una asimetría en
la vacunación en los países yo creo que
va a ser muy complejo y este par de
meses nos van a enseñar qué dinámica
tomar el ingreso de variantes a varios
países y conocí tomas decisiones después
doctor veíamos algunos artículos a lo
largo de esta semana sobre la
preocupación de la oms por el avance que
está teniendo la tuberculosis en el
marco de la pandemia del cob y 19 se han
descuidado los tratamientos para atender
esta enfermedad que dice la comunidad
científica al respecto
si es altísimamente preocupado hay una
gran cantidad de enfermedades que han
perdido su diagnóstico por ejemplo en el
cáncer o enfermedades metabólicas que no
han ido las personas a las atenciones
médicas les han descuidado pero el actor
culos es una de las enfermedades más
mortales que hay es prevenible y
tratable pero requiere un estricto
control de los pacientes en el
diagnóstico de la administración del
tratamiento
de esta pandemia en la teoría consulta
con la falta de acceso a los servicios
médicos muchos de estos pacientes no se
han diagnosticado llegan tarde y la
informe ha incrementado la mortalidad
hoy la tuberculosis nos preocupa
altísimamente por ser una enfermedad muy
prevalente en todos los países de
américa latina y porque su mortalidad se
ha incrementado por el retraso en el
diagnóstico y el tratamiento
doctor pasó a preguntarle por un estudio
publicado por la cepal y por la ope s
ellos han indicado que en américa latina
la vacunación contra el cob y 19a man
avanza de manera asimétrica debido a las
desigualdades que se presentan en el
sistema de salud en los diferentes
países en los sistemas privados y en los
sistemas públicos este tema ya lo hemos
tratado acá pero ellos hablan de cómo
mejorar esos sistemas de cara a unas
nuevas pandemias que puedan venir en el
futuro por donde se puede empezar para
mejorar los sistemas sanitarios los
sistemas de los hospitales y la
infraestructura en américa latina'
uno de los grandes problemas es que la
salud pública como tal se ha perdido ese
concepto de salud de todos se ha perdido
en varios países y se ha segmentado por
ejemplo por aseguradores en algunos
países que priman el aseguramiento o en
la medicina privada y la medicina
pública lo que hemos aprendido es que en
estas enfermedades como la tuberculosis
que mencionábamos ahora como el coi de
odio entre más virales no importa el
aseguramiento nos afecta a toda la
sociedad y si toda la sociedad se afecta
se afecta a la economía y por los
riesgos social debemos fortalecer los
sistemas de salud pública de vigilancia
el compartir los datos y compartirlas
esta actividad es exitosa y que la
política de salud global sea una
realidad en cada uno de los países
porque no podemos seguir fragmentando
más la población de acuerdo a las leyes
de mercado doctor pérez muchas gracias
por esta consulta para la teleaudiencia
de france 24 muchas gracias veamos ahora
cómo está avanzando la vacunación en el
continente americano les presento a
continuación el porcentaje de la
población con esquema de vacunación
completo en la región de centroamérica
vamos a comenzar en él en guatemala allí
él 15.97 de la población ya tiene el
esquema completo en el salvador las
cifras de alcanza el 55 punto 0 6 por
ciento honduras alcanza el 24 puntos 64
por ciento pasamos a nicaragua de
acuerdo a las cifras oficiales solamente
el 4 punto 90 por ciento de la gente ha
recibido ya el esquema completo allí en
este país aunque como lo decíamos el
observatorio ciudadano indica que la
cifra puede ser diferente costa rica
cierra esta semana con un 46 punto 62
por ciento de la población vacunada con
el esquema completo panamá alcanza el 53
punto 0 5 por ciento
un sector de la población de bolivia en
la ciudad de el alto tiene reservas
frente a las vacunas contra el cob y 19
pero para motivarlos a inmunizarse las
autoridades y también algunas empresas
privadas están regalando comida y
también garantizando el servicio de
autobuses para transportar a las
personas para que vayan hasta los
centros de vacunación esto lo que están
haciendo veamos
por favor
a regalar alimentos a cambio de la
primera dosis contra el co bit 19 es la
fórmula que está usando el alto la
segunda ciudad con mayor población de
bolivia para incentivar a personas como
el taxista gabriel navarro que hasta
ahora se había resistido a la vacunación
y
la mayoría va a venir como somos un poco
más necesitados así la gente se va a
animar también un poco más la vacunación
en el alto alcanza a un 43 por ciento
una cifra todavía baja estos números no
preocupan a otros habitantes de la misma
comunidad quienes no se dejan convencer
con incentivos entre ellos los grupos
evangelistas que justifican su rechazo
con la creencia de que la vacuna busca
controlar la natalidad hoy el miedo es
ya que nuestras esposas sean
esterilizadas ya que claramente estamos
entrando a un orden mundial para
desmentir la teoría de arequipa y
motivar a quienes se oponen a la
inmunización la alcaldesa de el alto e
bacopa defiende que la vacuna salvavidas
está bien no se quieren vacunar no les
vamos a obligar pero eso no les da el
derecho d e informar a la gente acerca
de la vacunación hemos visto de que la
gente no está entrando a terapia
intensiva por la vacuna además de donar
alimentos en el alto se han habilitado
autobuses para llevar la vacunación
hasta los barrios
aunque no son muchas las personas que se
suman al proceso las autoridades confían
en que sus campañas lograrán revertir
los datos negativos
en uruguay han mencionado la posibilidad
de levantar la obligatoriedad del uso de
la mascarilla en este país suramericano
vamos a hablar con karina da almas en la
ciudad de punta del este para conocer
más detalles hola carina pues denos más
detalles precisamente de esta medida que
puede implementar el gobierno uruguayo
el ministerio de salud pública de
uruguay cambió sus recomendaciones en
relación al uso de tapabocas son
mascarillas ya no será obligatorio en la
vida pública o en espacios abiertos en
general pero si si se registran hay
operaciones las autoridades sanitarias
dieron ejemplos en el caso de ir a
practicar ejercicio o caminar en la vía
pública dicen que no es obligatorio pero
si se participa por ejemplo de una
carrera de una maratón de algún
ejercicio al aire libre donde haya
muchas personas y el uso del tapabocas
es obligatorio y también el
distanciamiento social
así es que el presidente y luis lacalle
pou
participó por primera vez este jueves
dio un acto público sin el uso del
tapabocas
esto durante un acto oficial en las
fuerzas armadas pero luego cuando él
a un recinto interior allí el primer
mandatario si utilizo la mascarilla
lacalle pou señaló en reiteradas
oportunidades que espera poder hacer el
levantamiento de las medidas de la
emergencia sanitaria en cuanto sean
posibles y sé que él no considera
oportuno que el gobierno mantenga
medidas que restrinjan las libertades de
las personas por tiempos prolongados
karina uruguay va a ser la sede de la
final de la copa libertadores el 27 de
noviembre y ya la ocupación hotelera
está completamente vendida al igual que
los vuelos de ingreso a uruguay como
toman esta medida allí porque el país
apenas va a abrir las fronteras y ha
sido toda una discusión entre en la
parte económica que se beneficia y
también cómo puede afectar esto el
avance de la lucha contra la pandemia
así es la pasión por el fútbol la
posibilidad de disfrutar de un
espectáculo deportivo en un estadio como
es el estadio centenario en montevideo
ha hecho que más de 30.000 personas
hayan confirmado que en la semana del 27
de noviembre estarán visitando la
capital montevideana y es que justamente
el 27 de noviembre se va a disputar la
final de la copa libertadores entre
flamengo y palmeiras también esta semana
se estará desarrollando en montevideo la
finales de la copa libertadores femenino
y la final del sudamericano así que
muchos fanáticos de el deporte van a
estar visitando el país de hecho la
capacidad hotelera de tres departamentos
o provincias de uruguay está colmada al
100% es así que en algunas aplicaciones
cualquier es temporal y se pueden ver
apartamentos entre dos mil y cinco mil
dólares por el fin de semana del 27 de
noviembre es por eso que también las
autoridades de la ciudad de la capital
del país está revisando varias
planificaciones de eventos para hacer
que bueno los fanáticos del fútbol
disfruten también de la ciudad karina y
rápidamente por ese viento fuerte que
está teniendo hoy en punta del este le
preguntó por esta encuesta que muestra
una división en cuanto a algunas
opiniones entre los uruguayos entre
abrir o no las fronteras del país
durante estos meses de pandemia se han
realizado varias encuestas para ver la
visión de la población en relación a las
medidas del gobierno para paliar la
pandemia del cob y 19 en la mayoría de
los casos la visión ha sido favorable
sobre todo en torno a la acción del
presidente luis lacalle pou en relación
a la emergencia sanitaria esta
aprobación llegó a un máximo histórico
este mes pasado con un 84 por ciento de
la población aprobando las medidas del
presidente luis lacalle pou sin embargo
cuando se les pregunta sobre la apertura
de las fronteras a partir del primero de
noviembre solamente el 50 por ciento de
la población aprueba esta medida
entretanto el ministerio de salud
pública anunció que ofrecerá una dosis
de refuerzo para los turistas que
ingresen al país recordemos a partir del
primero de noviembre se abren las
fronteras para todos los turistas que
estén 100% vacunados contra el cob y 19
también se ofrecerán vacunas a los
menores de edad que la soliciten gracias
karina por este reporte desde la ciudad
de punta del este en uruguay hablamos
ahora de eeuu el gobierno de este país
allí están enfrentadas con las
autoridades del estado de texas
mantienen opiniones diferentes en torno
a la vacunación la casa blanca ordenó
que los empleados de empresas privadas
que tengan más de 100 trabajadores
tienen que vacunarse de manera
obligatoria pero el gobernador del
estado de texas greg abbott desafió la
decisión y levantó la obligatoriedad en
su territorio así están las cosas
un nuevo desafío para la casa blanca el
anuncio del presidente joe biden de que
los trabajadores de empresas privadas
con más de 100 empleados debían
vacunarse o hacerse una prueba semanal
de kobe 19 y que en caso contrario
podrían enfrentarse a multas hasta de 14
mil dólares americanos no fue del agrado
de algunos líderes conservadores
especialmente de greg abbott el
gobernador de texas quien eximió a su
estado de este mandato el gobernador
greg abbott emitió hoy una orden
ejecutiva que establece que ninguna
entidad en texas puede obligar a recibir
una vacuna contra el cob y 19 a
cualquier individuo
un empleado o consumidor que se oponga a
dicha vacuna por cualquier motivo de
conciencia personal basado en una
creencia religiosa o por razones médicas
incluidas la recuperación previa de kobe
19 una decisión que la casa blanca ha
criticado james aquí la secretaria de
prensa habló al respecto caminar la
orden objetivo del gobernador abbott que
prohibió los mandatos y también quisiera
señalar el anuncio del gobernador de
santis esta mañana que esencialmente
prohíbe la implementación de mandatos se
ajusta a un patrón familiar que hemos
visto anteponiendo la política a la
salud pública más de 700 mil vidas
estadounidenses se han perdido debido al
cubil 19 incluidas más de 56 mil en
florida y más de 68 mil en texas texas
cabe recalcar que texas y florida
figuran entre los tres estados más
afectados por la pandemia sólo lo
superan california según la organización
our world in that a eeuu hasta el
momento ha vacunado con el esquema
completo al 57 por ciento de su
población total y esta semana también
eeuu anunció que la ventana levantará
las restricciones para el ingreso de
ciudadanos
pero será obligatorio tener el esquema
completo de vacunación alto nivel si nos
va a dar más detalles desde la ciudad de
miami anthony gracias por acompañarnos
hoy en el programa y hablemos del
desmonte de estas restricciones para los
viajeros internacionales
pues sí qué tal muy buenas tardes
santiago eeuu ya ha confirmado la fecha
en la que oficialmente se reabrirán las
fronteras después de 19 meses de
cerradas será el 8 de noviembre y se
requerirá una prueba negativa y la pauta
completa de la vacuna contra el
coronavirus pero atención porque no
todas las vacunas están reconocidas por
el gobierno norteamericano las que
tienen la luz verde de la organización
mundial de la salud sí que sirven por lo
tanto los que se han inoculado con la de
moderna pzifer jansen oxford astrazéneca
también su versión india como visible
scinopharm y si novak podrán entrar esta
medida como comentaba es deja de lado a
millones de latinoamericanos que se han
puesto las dosis de sputnik soberana
abdalá y también la vacuna china
argentina a bolivia méxico guatemala
nicaragua venezuela honduras son algunos
de los países que en su momento
compraron millones de dosis de esas
vacunas para administrar entre su
población a pesar de que a día de hoy
aún no tienen la aprobación de la oms
por lo que no estarían reconocidas por
las autoridades migratorias de eeuu el
ministro ruso de salud señaló que el
registro de la vacuna es público ya
había pasado todo el proceso y se espera
que pudiera estar reconocida por el
organismo sanitario a finales de este
año pero de momento
esperar santiago antonio y también
destacado esta semana ese anuncio de las
autoridades de abrir la frontera con
méxico y con canadá que me has dicho al
respecto al yen washington
si también la administración de joe
biden ha anunciado que eliminará las
restricciones de viaje con méxico y
canadá a partir de noviembre pero eso sí
los que quieran cruzar la frontera a pie
también tendrán que estar completamente
vacunados anteriormente los choferes
comerciales estudiantes y otro personal
esencial sí que podía entrar al país sin
ningún requisito pero ahora se requerirá
a todo el mundo que esté vacunado esa
decisión también permitirá el reingreso
de turistas y también la reunión de
familiares que quedaron separados y
fuera del país durante la pandemia sin
duda estas medidas que estamos
comentando marcarán la reapertura del
turismo un sector que ha quedado
gravemente afectado sobre todo por las
restricciones que se han impuesto en los
vuelos también en los cruceros y en
otros negocios relacionados eso también
es un síntoma de recuperación después de
casi dos años con una actividad
extremadamente limitada santiago antonio
muchas gracias por este reporte desde la
ciudad de miami en el sur del estado de
la florida ahora nos vamos hasta ecuador
el ministerio de salud de ese país
anunció que vacunará a los niños entre 5
y 11 años contra el cob y 19 los menores
que tengan cinco años van a dosis de
facer y los de 6 años en adelante la de
sinovac pero también hay familias que
están preocupadas por la vacunación de
sus hijos veamos
la mandinga es madre de valentín de 5
años de edad no está dispuesta a acatar
el llamado del gobierno ecuatoriano para
vacunar a su hijo contra el commit 19 su
postura radical anti vacunas proviene de
que pone en duda la temporalidad con la
que fueron desarrolladas y también la
desconfianza en el sistema de salud
ecuatoriano
nos parece que no tenemos
suficientemente distancia para ver qué
ocurriría con esta vacuna al grupo de
los niños y de las niñas sobre todo que
sabemos que no son un grupo digamos de
los más vulnerables a este virus
entonces nuestro caso
calculando un poquito vemos que hay como
más riesgo de vacunar a nuestros hijos
que de no vacunar los
el pediatra fernando aguinaga difiere de
la negativa de amante de no permitir la
inoculación de su hijo e insiste que la
vacuna no causará un daño letal a los
infantes muchas madres se lo piensan si
nosotros hablamos del cob y te vamos a
ir si la mayoría no es una enfermedad
grave entonces yo creo que cuando la
mayoría madres reflexiona sobre este
tema mucho va a cambiar de opinión y
ojalá logremos esta vacunación masiva la
haría comer lucrecia nunca le ha puesto
ninguna vacuna a su hijo lautaro de 9
años no es partidaria de las
inoculaciones sin embargo decidió
permitir que le apliquen la ley com y 19
para protegerlo porque su trabajo lo
pone un estado de vulnerabilidad ante el
contagio bueno yo tengo un local atiendo
personas
bueno personas variadas que no sé de
dónde provienen y cuál es su nivel de
protección ante el hobbit amandi y
lucrecia com opiniones similares tomaron
decisiones opuestas para resguardar la
salud de sus hijos estas determinaciones
de muchas madres y su gran en la meta de
ecuador de alcanzar la inmunidad de
rebaño antes del fin de año
una cifra alentadora brasilia superó las
100 millones de personas que han
recibido al menos una dosis de alguna de
las vacunas que está disponible en
brasil contra el cob y 19 también las
autoridades anunciaron el esperado
regreso a clases presenciales de manera
obligatoria vamos a conocer los detalles
con valeria sakon en nuestra
corresponsal en la ciudad de río de
janeiro hola valeria comenzamos
precisamente por esa cifra alentadora
100 millones de brasileños ya tienen al
menos una dosis de alguna vacuna contra
el joven 19
brasil ha superado la cifra simbólica de
más de 100 millones de personas
totalmente vacunadas es una buena
noticia en un país que tiene más de
600.000 víctimas de el coronavirus y que
empezó tarde y mal' el proceso de
vacunación también debido a una actitud
algo negacionista del actual gobierno
además el 70% de la población ya recibió
la primera dosis de esta forma brasil es
el cuarto país del mundo que aplica más
dosis de vacunas pero si lo vemos en
términos proporcionales ocupa el número
60 del ranking es una buena noticia
brasil es un país que tiene una gran
tradición de vacunación y gracias a este
avance de la tasa de mortalidad ha
bajado mucho pero hay que recordar que
la vacunación avanza a trompicones y de
repente varias ciudades tienen que
interrumpir el proceso por falta de
suministro pero también hay que decir
que los pocos días se reanuda y así se
va avanzando hacia la inmunización de
esta población de 213 millones de
por su parte el presidente de
revolucionarios sigue sin querer se
vacunar dijo en varias ocasiones que
tienen muchos anticuerpos naturales porn
que contrajo el año pasado el
coronavirus pero eso contradice las
recomendaciones de los expertos y de la
propia organización mundial de la salud
hay que recordar que en septiembre
cuando visitó nueva york para hablar
delante de la onu el no pudo ser no pudo
acceder a los restaurantes y fue muy
criticado él y su delegación por no
querer se vacunar fue flagrante como
pizza en las aceras de nueva york' y
finalmente cuatro personas de su
delegación
contrajeron el coronavirus entre ellos
el propio ministro de la salud y el hijo
diputado de bolsonaro eduardo bolsonaro
valeria hablemos ahora de ese posible
regreso a clases presenciales por lo
menos en el estado de sao paulo que
dicen las autoridades allí
a partir del 18 de octubre todos los
alumnos de las escuelas públicas del
estado de san paulo están obligados a
volver a clase esta decisión anunciada
por el gobierno local ha sido duramente
criticada por una parte de la sociedad
pero en el gobierno local están
convencidos de que no hay riesgo porque
el
97% de los profesores están totalmente
inmunizados así como el 90% de los
alumnos de entre 12 y 17 años
además se observarán medidas de
seguridad mascarilla obligatoria y una
separación de por lo menos un metro
entre los alumnos sin embargo una parte
de los padres y de los profesores
critican que todavía no se realizaron
obras en muchas escuelas para poder
asegurar esta distancia de seguridad que
por tanto sería prematuro volver a clase
pero sampalo no está solo y otros nueve
estados han anunciado que quieren volver
a clase brasil intenta recuperar una
normalidad tras dos años casi de
pandemia y de hecho el ayuntamiento de
san paolo
cree que va a poder celebrar el año que
viene el carnaval dicen que se va a
poder hacer y que esperan a 15 millones
de personas 15 millones de personas
celebrando el carnaval valeria muchas
gracias por este reporte desde rio de
janeiro en cuba los menores de edad ya
están volviendo también a las aulas así
como les espera a los alumnos en sao
paulo el curso 2020 2021 fue reanudado
gradualmente en prácticamente ya todas
las provincias de cuba aunque no es un
requisito obligatorio las autoridades
les recomiendan a los estudiantes que
asistan tener por lo menos las tres
dosis que indica el protocolo de las
vacunas abdalá y soberana que son hechas
en cuba'
'cuba da un paso hacia adelante la
nación caribeña ha reanudado el curso
escolar 2020 2021 con la reincorporación
progresiva de los estudiantes a las
aulas y prevé que para el 14 de
noviembre más de 1.6 millones de alumnos
ya estudian de manera presencial pero se
mantienen las medidas sanitarias estamos
diciendo mucho con nuestros estudiantes
con la familia que hay que cumplir las
medidas higiénico-sanitarias el uso del
lazo grupo el distanciamiento los pasos
ováricos la desinfección con hipoclorito
esto ha sido posible gracias al esquema
completo de inmunización con las vacunas
cubanas contra el kobe 19 la bda la
soberana 2 y soberana plus con las que
actualmente son inoculados hasta
infantes de 2 años sin embargo estos
fármacos aún no han sido aprobados por
la organización mundial de salud por lo
cual las personas que han recibido estas
vacunas enfrentan restricciones de
viajes el ministerio de salud de este
país espera una respuesta positiva por
parte de este organismo internacional
la suficiente experiencia de la vida
reconoce
de hecho tras todas las vacunas que
nosotros tenemos en nuestro país que son
personas sanas hoy están reconocidas por
este importante
a medida que sigamos los pasos que están
establecidos con esto
no es trabajo una contra
el gobierno cubano apunta a inocular
completamente al 90% de sus ciudadanos
contra el coronavirus para diciembre
según la organización our world in data
cerca del 57% de la población cubana ya
fue inmunizada por completo hasta el
momento más de 900 mil personas han
contraído el virus en este país y más de
8 mil han muerto por esta causa
y brevemente les presentamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana en
nuestro continente méxico producirá
localmente la vacuna rusa sputnik ve
esto gracias a un acuerdo firmado con el
fondo ruso de inversión directa que le
permitirá al laboratorio birmex llevar a
cabo la transferencia tecnológica y
analítica para producir la vacuna que no
cuenta con el aval de la oms efe y
tampoco de la unión europea chile
reportó mil 703 casos de kobe 19 esta es
la cifra más alta en los últimos tres
meses así lo dio a conocer el ministerio
de salud de ese país suramericano que
indicó que es la mayor cifra de casos de
contagio en 85 días con la pandemia bajo
control también con menos restricciones
y con una alta vacunación las
autoridades se mostraron tranquilas pese
a este aumento porque la tasa de
ocupación de las ucis por kobe 19 está
solamente en el 21 por ciento y
brevemente también les cuento que
argentina presentó los resultados
preliminares de su primer estudio sobre
la combinación de vacunas los cuales
fueron positivos sobre todo en casos de
escasez de vacunas como precisamente le
pasó a argentina la combinación de
vacuna puede ser muy efectiva para
mantener altos ritmos de inmunización en
la población dando seguridad y un alto
porcentaje de inmunogenicidad en la
población
y perú endureció su plan de vacunación
ahora todos los empleados sanitarios
tienen que estar con el esquema completo
para ir presencialmente a sus trabajos
así las cosas para el próximo mes de
noviembre todos los mayores de 45 años
tendrán que tener todas las dosis
completas de las vacunas contra el cob y
19 para poder viajar también entre los
diferentes departamentos de perú
de otra parte comenzó la inoculación
nacional para los mayores de 18 años
ariana villacorta nos cuenta más en su
informe
pero avanza en la campaña de vacunación
contra el kobe y 19 esta semana el país
andino empezó a vacunar a los mayores de
18 años y ya se empiezan a ver los
resultados luego de seis meses que
produce un leve descenso efectivamente
de los niveles de defensas a pesar de
todo si es que se aplica a la población
que lo haga nos han dado excelentes
resultados y la muestra está en cómo ha
descendido la mortalidad y el número
pero este junto con esto
hay un tema que tiene que ver con la
exposición que tienen los trabajadores
del sector salud con pacientes con kobe
aun así el colegio médico de perú afirma
que la mortalidad en el personal médico
se redujo en un 95% con la vacunación
además ya se aplica a la tercera dosis
para los trabajadores de la salud en
primera línea y en unos meses el resto
de la población podrá hacer lo mismo el
ministro ceballos señaló que el gobierno
ha contratado con pzifer la provisión de
35 millones de dosis que llegarán desde
abril del 2022 lo que permitiría aplicar
una dosis de refuerzo a toda la
población
de acuerdo a un estudio realizado por la
universidad johns hopkins más de dos
millones de personas han contraído el
virus en este país el 80 por ciento de
los nuevos contagios se atribuyen a la
variante delta además más de 200.000 han
fallecido por coronavirus y el 94% de
las muertes a causa del cobi 19 desde
febrero de este año corresponden a
personas no vacunadas
y ahora demos un vistazo a otras
noticias relacionadas con la pandemia de
kobe 19 destacadas en redes nuestros
compañeros de la redacción web de france
24 punto com publicaron lo siguiente o
ms conforman nuevo grupo de expertos
para esclarecer el origen del cobi 19
dicho grupo estará conformado por 26
expertos para realizar nuevas
investigaciones con mejores estrategias
para determinar el origen de la pandemia
y también posibles nuevos brotes y para
el cierre tenemos esta publicación de la
agencia efe el gobierno de costa rica
afirma el decreto sobre la
obligatoriedad de la vacuna anti kobe
para los trabajadores del sector público
también abre la opción para que el
sector privado pueda exigir la a sus
empleados la medida aspira a aumentar la
inmunidad entre los ciudadanos para
evitar más contagios muertes y también
las hospitalizaciones
ese fue nuestro resumen aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa en nombre del
equipo de producción compuesto por laura
garzón y ariana villacorta les
agradecemos también a nuestros
compañeros del máster que ayudan en la
transmisión a todos ustedes gracias por
la sintonía nos vemos la próxima semana
hasta entonces
[Música]